[Música]
y yo que el momento de hablar de revista
de prensa para ello ya está conmigo
lista en el estudio rosa pérez más euros
a bienvenida feliz lunes iniciamos
semana entonces con la prensa británica
porque rosa porque ahora los ataques van
hacia la esposa del primer ministro
británico
boris johnson hablamos de xavi johnson
que dice un al respecto vamos ahora a
hablar con el medio the times y sky news
buenos días raúl exactamente ambos
medios británicos destacan que el
secretario de salud ha salido en defensa
de la primera dama no en ambos titulares
vemos que pide que cesen los ataques
sexistas contra carrie johnson porque
esta polémica se remonta a que durante
el fin de semana michael ashcroft que es
empresario y ex parlamentario
conservador en el reino unido ha
publicado en el daily mail un extracto
de su libro primera dama intriga en la
corte de carril y boris johnson y
básicamente en este extracto en estas
líneas defiende la tesis de que los
problemas en downing street son culpa de
carrie johnson de la primera dama que
tiene una influencia desmedida sobre el
ejecutivo británico y bien a raúl así
por un lado ambos medios señalan que
ciertamente carrie johnson parece que
fue la organizadora de esta fiesta de
cumpleaños de boris johnson que se
celebró durante el confinamiento parece
fuera de lugar que se use como cabeza de
turco una cargo no electo no de los
problemas que bueno a la luz de los
hechos si parece que tiene downing
street claro que sí rosa y además ha
entraron y si se pueden decir si ya
tuviera esa iniciativa no se puede hacer
porque estamos en confinamiento y
respetar las reglas bueno continuamos
que una vista puesta en reino unido-
vamos con al yazira porque realice una
serie de infografías con datos que
explican el reinado de la reina isabel
segunda exacto porque este pues 6 de
febrero se cumplieron 70 años del
reinado de isabel segunda y este medio
lo que hace es con distintos gráficos
señalar momentos relevantes de la
historia de la monarca que es
indisociable ya de la historia reciente
del reino unido y nos hemos ha querido
fijar particularmente en dos
infográficos en uno de ellos muestra una
línea histórica con los acontecimientos
que ha vivido no y sabe la segunda a la
frente de la casa real del reino unido
por ejemplo que en el 52 llegó al trono
cuando winston churchill era primer
ministro por otro lado cuando estaba
también evidentemente al frente de la
casa real en el 73 cuando el reino unido
se unió a la comunidad económica europea
no era esta organización que predecía a
la unión europea por otro lado también
durante la guerra de las malvinas y el
gobierno de margaret thatcher o durante
la guerra de edad bajo el ejecutivo de
tony blair así como en 2016 cuando tuvo
lugar la votación progresiva a todo esto
ha sobrevivido la reina isabel segunda
bueno rosa y cambiamos radicalmente de
tema o nos vamos a colombia titula así
este medio que vamos a ver a
continuación la impunidad es la regla en
las muertes por cirugías estéticas en
ese país rosa que está pasando pues esta
es una entrevista de la de la periodista
catalina oquendo a lorena bertrán que se
define como una activista después de
haber sido víctima de un cirujano que le
destruyó los durante una operación de
cirugía estética y lo que denuncia
beltrán ahora es la impunidad con la que
salen los supuestos doctores que
practican este tipo de cirugías con
sustancias nocivas para el cuerpo o sin
tener los conocimientos necesarios pues
en términos de salud de anatomía humana
y destaca que pues por mucho que se
denunció en casos así la secretaría de
salud llega a cerrar estas consultas
pero que se vuelven a reabrir bajo en
nombres distintos de los profesionales
que supuestamente tienen los diplomas
concretamente a lorena beltrán denunció
una lista de más de 40 cirujanos que se
hacían llamar cirujanos y que realmente
no tenían título seis de ellos están
imputados pero dice siguen ejerciendo a
pesar de que teóricamente pues no
podrían hacerlo y de hecho ella dice que
el hecho que ya llegue a denunciar es un
caso muy poco habitual porque la mayoría
de mujeres tienen que decidir entre
pagar un abogado o una reconstrucción
después de estos casos y pues termina
esta entrevista con un párrafo en el que
dice esto denuncias tocan intereses que
afectan a personas muy poderosas que han
demostrado que pueden silenciar a la
justicia dilatar procesos comprar
pacientes y abrir y cerrar sus clínicas
clandestinas cuando quieran un gran tema
raúl en aquí en colombia una de las
puntos mundiales de esta gran industria
de la belleza por cierto la conozco rosa
y desde aquí pues le aplaudo su lucha
seguimos en este país porque renace una
mítica revista en colombia cambio en su
primera etapa llegó a contar con el
primer nobel de literatura gabriel
garcía márquez rosa exacto esta revista
que se fundó primeramente en
1993 como versión colombiana de cambio
16 en españa' ahora pues se cerró
digamos en 2010 y ahora vuelve a renacer
va a contar con un modelo de negocio
basado en la suscripción pero durante
esta primera semana ofrece sus
contenidos en abierto y queríamos
destacar algunos de los titulares con
los que vuelve a abrir esta revista
entre otros temas encontramos pues los
problemas internos dentro del partido en
el poder aquí en colombia dentro del
centro democrático por otro lado o
también titula la guerra entre las
disidencias por el putumayo para
controlar rutas de exportación de la
cocaína o los genes y desata la locura
por el cripto arte